foreign
[Music]
and welcome to today's webinar tools and
strategies for implementing ipsc based
cell models for neurodegenerative
disease drug discovery
I'm Kaylee Bach of labyrinths and I'll
be your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by labroots and brought to you
by bioneer as
to learn more about our sponsor please
visit bioneer.dk
we encourage you to participate today by
submitting any questions you may have
during the presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask a
question box and click Send we'll answer
as many questions as we have time for at
the end of the presentation
you may also submit any technical issues
here as well if you have trouble seeing
or hearing the presentation
I'd like to now welcome our speakers
Benjamin Schmidt senior scientist at
bioneer as
and Peter Reinhardt principal research
scientist team leads cell programming
and transduction Medicinal Chemistry and
screening biology Neuroscience Discovery
ABV
Benjamin Peter you may now begin your
presentation
hello all together it's my pleasure to
talk today together with my former PhD
fellow Peter Reinhardt we have been
doing our PhD together in Germany like
10 years ago and it's my pleasure to
talk to you today together with him and
we are going to talk about tools and
strategies for implementing ipsl based
cell models for new new deteriorated
disease drug discovery
so before I jump into my presentation I
will quickly like to introduce Pioneer
we are a Danish specialty CIO which is
operating worldwide so we are taking
um service contract Service and
um I'm representing today the CNS
Department of our of pioneer
and we are using IPS cell technology
combined with Crystal Gene editing
technology and differentiation to a
newly generated two neurons to Modern
new degenerative diseases
so a quick introduction to ipsl
technology that was first described in
um 15 years ago in 2007 for humans and
2006 for mice
in his Labs who described it first how
to
reprogram already somatic cells in this
case they used skin cells to a group
potent State and they found out that you
have to over Express or factors which
are cmic or sox2 and klf4 and then you
can reprogram an already differentiated
somatic cell to a blue potent stem cell
so
our skin biopsy can be taken from a
patient or from a healthy control and
the fibroblasts can be cultivated in in
cell culture and then the four factors
have to be overexpressed at today it's
normally done by uh non non-integrating
viruses and then you obtain these uh
blue potent induced blueprint stem cells
which are Immortal which are
self-reneurial
and you can differentiate them to all
desired cell types blood cells kidney
cells liver cells and of course also
neurons and then you can use these
Newtons either for disease modeling and
Drug Discovery and the hope of course is
also to use these differentiated cells
for cell replacement Therapies
in order to exploit the full potential
of ips cell technology it's very often
combined with Crystal cas9 Gene editing
technology what we are using as a
service offering as a service
so for the generation of knockout lines
or for the generation of isogenic Gene
corrected controls or insertion of
mutations or report Alliance
that's what we are offering as a service
and I would like to quickly go through
the workflow that we are using
we bring in the crispr cas9 complex into
our living cells into the IPS cells with
uh with a nuclear factor from amaxa
and then normally typically a few days
after
nuclection we are sorting the cells with
a single cell Sorter and here in-house
we are using the excite from cytina
and we are sorting the cells out into a
96 well plate so to make sure that we
are looking at monoclonal populations
when we are screening our cells
so and then a few weeks later we are
screening those cells so when they are
when they have grown dense enough they
are split into a replica plate that we
are keeping in cell culture and into a
DNA plate and this DNA plate is then
screened by for example just by PCR if
it's possible or within restriction
enzyme essay
and based on this screening we are
selecting then positive clones candidate
clones which are then confirmed by
sequencing we Trace these clones back in
the cell culture files in there and
split them we Bank them and then finally
we are performing quality controls
and I will later on in this presentation
uh elaborate a little bit more what
these qualities controls are
now
I would quickly like to give you an
overview to the different approaches for
Gene editing I would say 50 of our work
is the generation of knockout lines
that's for some reason the most
appealing uh Gene editing approach that
uh most of our customers actually want
to have
so knocking out a certain machine to
study its function
then um also very often quite often
approach a single-based modifications
which I would say maybe 20 where we are
inserting mutations into a healthy donor
line into an IPS align that is actually
from a healthy individual
but we can of course also if available
if we have IPS cells with a certain
mutation we can correct this mutation
then it has also become more and more
popular uh this is not the third point
the insertion of inducible genes into
safe side loci we have mainly used the
AVS one Locus in our lab here but we
have also worked on different loci in
the meanwhile and what we also have done
is insertion of reported Gene where you
can that allows for tracking the
expression of a certain Gene during
differentiation for example if you
couple a gene with a gfp or to localize
the gene in the cells
so I would quickly like to uh talk about
the technique that we are using for
these different approaches uh knockout
is normally generated with the
combination of two Crispers which are
cutting close to each other so you can
see here a draft of a gene and two
Crispers which are located one crispr is
located in the axon and the other crispr
is located in the downstream intern so
we are removing the so-called Supply
Stone aside from this axon and we
typically use the axon which is the
first actual axon which is present in
all known isoforms of the gene and then
for screening we have two sets of
primers and the first set is surrounding
the deletion which is called in which we
are calling the detection essay PCR set
and for the absence for the other set
one of the which is called which we call
the absence sapcr test one of the
primers is located within the region
that was deleted
so for screening these clones we just
carry out a simple PCR and with the
detection essay which is shown here at
the left side
um you expect for wild type loans a
certain size of the PCR product and for
mock out clones you expect a shorter PCR
product because you have cut out a part
of the piece of the Gene and in the
AdSense essay for wild type loans you
also expect a certain size of the PCR
product and you expect that for knockout
clones that the piece output that no PCR
product is present
so trust as an example how that looks
like practically practically in lab we
are normally screening 96 clones in 96
well played and you can see
um here different clones and clone
number one
uh you can see as has the wild type
sequence with the size of the wild type
product
and accordingly to this at the right
side you see the absence essay you have
a PCR product because the wild type
sequence is still present
if you look at the second band clone
number two we have a shorter PCR product
which corresponds to the size of The
Knockout and corresponding to that we
don't have PCR product in the absence
essay at the right side and then the
third example is shown in Clone number
three where we have both products and
that was obviously a clone where only
one allele was
destroyed and the other allele was still
one type and of course you would expect
a product in the absence essay because
one earlier is still present
so if we now look at clone number two
this uh fulfilled the criteria of the
detection and the absence essay
we have a template of the sequence and
in blue capital letters you can see the
exonic region and in black small letters
we can see the intronic region and we
have cut out the yellow part
here and when we now sequence our clone
then we can indeed confirm that this
part was cut out this is a very easy way
very easy and efficient way to screen
for knockout clones and to generate more
out clones and by cutting out a part of
the Exon and fusing this part to the
subsequent intro you are normally
generating a cryptic sequence that the
cells can't interpret and then
the product undergoes
nonsense midi hdk or sometimes you are
also generating a stop codon later on
which then leads to liquidation
and I would like to give an example for
the strategy to correct a mutation or to
insert a mutation
here we are normally using one crystal
in combination with one homologous
template and as a homologous template
it's most convenient to just use a
single stranded oligod deoxynucleotide
and ssodn which is a short primer if you
want of 100 base pairs
and this is homologous to your Gene of
interest but it contains of course a
mutation so one base is different and
for the screening we have only one
primer pair and a sequencing primer pair
and we designed these um ssodns in a way
that we are creating a cut inside for
restriction enzyme enzyme and then the
PCR product
if we have a successfully genetic
genetically modified clone that the PCR
product is cut by a certain enzyme
this looks then as follows at the very
left side you can see a wild type clone
which has a certain piece of our product
and even if this is treated with the
enzyme it's not cut because it was not
modified for heterozygous clones you
would expect that one allele is indeed
recognized by the enzyme and then Cuts
so you get this pattern which is shown
in the middle and for homozygous clones
we have both alleles which are cut
and this is just an example so uh
normally the efficiency of these single
base modifications is much lower so we
have to screen many more clones for such
an approach but here you can see marked
by the arrows we have heterozygous
clones and homozygous clones so you have
candidate clones and those clones have
then to be confirmed by sequencing and
that's what we are using in-house
Thunder sequencing
and you can see here a sequence for the
wild type for the wild type Gene for
heterozygous Gene and for a homozygous
Gene
foreign
I would like to quickly mention using
this technique we have generated a set
of isogenic lines comprising four
different lines for ebis which is the
European bank and use group within stem
cells and all the lines which are
deposited at ebis are available for
everyone
and we have generated three sets of
isogenic lines with different upper e
genotypes
I'm only mentioning that because they
have become very popular in the past so
and since we are talking about CNS I
would like to just mention we have
generated presets and they are
consisting of different genotypes
Apple e is the most important risk
factor for Alzheimer's disease and we
have generated the main genotypes of e22
which is protective for Alzheimer's e33
which is neutral and upper e44 which is
a show associated with a higher risk of
Alzheimer's disease and we also included
a line which has an upper e-lock out so
all these lines are isogenic and from
of this set for this set we have to we
have generated the set in three
different IPS slides
and all of them are deposited at ebisk
and publicly available
now the strategy for insertion of
inducible genes in a safe side loci
here we normally have the strategy that
we insert uh two different expression
headsets on the both alleles in for
example the aeb is one the Adeno
Associated virus one Locus
and on one allele we insert a so-called
tetral cycling Trends activator which is
constitutively expressed
however nothing happens unless you are
adding docs and when you're adding docs
it will bind to the tetracy entrance
activator this will then bind to the
other allele where we have a
tetracycline responsive element and this
drives then a certain Gene of Interest
g4i
and this is interchangeable of course
there will be some examples later in
this presentation and then the chain of
interest is expressed
so you have a line that expresses the
option of Interest after a docs Edition
so comparing this safe site low side
Gene editing with conventional methods
for example why was my virus methods
where we have inserted the gene of
Interest with a virus
using the crispr gene editing we have a
defined integration at a certain site
versus for viruses we normally have
random integration and there you always
have of course the risk that you destroy
a gene by a random integration if the
device jumps into a certain those type
of G
we have only one integration using the
crispr gene editing approach while
versus multiple Integrations and that
can also lead to a lot of variabilities
for the expression
and that of course leads to even if
you're comparing different lines you
have a very comparable expression level
when you have the safe cycle side chain
editing compared to viruses where you
can have a
where the expression level can differ a
lot
and then of course for the critical
change approach you don't have to work
in a safety class 2 lab
um it's a normal cell culture lab
whereas this with viruses you have to
work in safety class 2. now
so after we have found positive clones
uh we normally Bank them uh in freezing
ones and store them in an nitrogen tank
and then we're using we are using one
while for Quality controls and what we
are offering as the quality controls is
of course that the cells are still
viable after we have Bank them so we
fall one while and one day later we are
taking pictures showing that the cells
are still viable we normally carry out a
microplasma test by PCR
for the plants that we are generating we
do an identity test by Str analysis
showing that the Clone that we had
genetically modified is the same as the
parental line
we do genotyping by sequencing to
confirm that the banked clones have
indeed the genetic modification that's
unlike standard sequencing
then we do different blowing potency
tests either by expression of stem cell
markers or by true lineage
differentiation
this is carried out either by staining
or by flow cytometry but also by qrt PCR
experiments
sometimes we are also checking for
principle of Target effects this is
however very rare and not a lot of
customers have requested this so far
and then we are also carrying uh
carrying out the KO type analyzes this
is not what we are doing in-house this
is g-bending karyotyping and we also do
a snip analyzes which is done on a DNA
chip
which tells you which is kind of a high
molecular uh cheap ending karyotype if
you want
so for disease modeling we exclusively
work only with Gene edited lines with
isogenic lines so we start normally with
an ipslion which has a mutation which we
are correcting using the crystal cas9
technology and since we are working
mainly on new deteriorated diseases we
differentiate them to neurons and then
we compare these humans and since we
have isagenic lines we can detect very
subtle changes in these neurons
while we are using isogenic lines this
is goes back to a study that we have
done together Peter and me in 2013 where
we have compared different isogenic
lines with agent General merch controls
and this is
um gene expression profiling so it's a
cluster dendrogram and what we found is
that the patient lines clustered most
closely related to their hydrogen Gene
correct counterparts so igc stands for
isagen Gene reactor
so by the height and the classic
dendrogram you can see how closely they
are how how close they are clustering
together
and um you can see that the isotonic
lines for both of the patients and the
different clones that we were using are
very similar uh even after
differentiation so this was actually
taken after 30 days of differentiation
and when you look at control one you can
see that control one was actually
um
uh paired regarding children age for
page one it was clustering more closely
with patient two and control 2 which was
matched regarding 10 and age to Patient
2 was quite different from all the other
lines
so this was only meant to show you the
power of Gene editing and the benefits
of Gene editing that you have that you
don't have to deal with uh individual
variabilities from a different genomic
background
so and now I would like to give you a
short uh case study where which we have
done together with utsan and Christine
Floyd from the University of Copenhagen
a few years ago this involved IPS
Alliance from patients with a mutation
in the teaching to be
um is involved in Anderson trafficking
and mutations in this Gene lead to
frontal temporal dementia FTD
which is associated with the generation
of the cortex
and we had three patient lines and for
all the three patients we generated an
isogenic Gene corrected control
and we also included independent
controls IPS cells from independent
controls which were uh match we got in
general h
we differentiated these IQs cells using
a protocol which was published in 2009
Chambers
this involves the usage of two
Inhibitors which are inhibiting the
smart signaling pathway
and by that after 15 days you end up
with new progenitor cells which are
self-renewal and which can be kept in
culture they can be frozen down and from
this stage you can carry on
and mature those nuclear challenges in
our case to cortical neurons
but they can also be differentiated to
other kind of immune's motor neurons or
dopamineergic ruins has been shown
um depending on the patterning factors
that you're going to use in your
maturation medium
and then after 6 to 12 weeks
um you're typically carrying out the
analyzes
so we first characterized our neurons
and at the right side you can see a
draft of the layers the different layers
of the cortex and there are different
markers for example tbr1 ctip2 set V2
and brain two and we investigated these
markers by Amino starter fluorescence
and we found that all these markers were
expressed
so then since
um chimp to be is involved in endosome
trafficking we had a look at the
endosons using electron microscopy and
there are three different types the
nuisance endosomes which are shown on
top which are large endosomes that do
not have any inclusions then we have
endosomes with moderate amount of
inclusions and we have the very dense
inclusions shown on the bottom
so we Quantified these um endosomes and
we found that the area of the endosomes
was larger and that the amount of the
news and endosomes was higher in the
mutant lines compared to the isogeneity
controls and the independent control
in this study we also looked at the
mitochondria and in this case we looked
at the inner life of the mitochondria at
the Crystal and we found a significantly
higher number of mitochondria in the
patient lines which were missing these
crystals and that was Quantified
and also compare to the isogenic
controls showing a significantly higher
amount of these mitochondria lacking the
these crystals
so this was just meant as a simple
example how we have been doing disease
modeling for a new new detonate of
disease
um and how a single base modification
actually can lead to a phenotypic change
in your ipsl derived neurons
another very uh interesting tool for
disease modeling is the induction of
ngn2 Doxycycline and usable Engine 2
which we typically insert into the AV is
one Locus safe side Locus
we have deposited several lines at ebisk
which have such an inducible engine and
two Gene in the avs-1 locus and these
lines have become more and more popular
because it makes it very easy to
differentiate them in a very short time
to functional uh neurons so to come from
these IPS Alliance within only six days
to a very neuronal looking like a
network
we also characterize these neurons I
think Peter has some much nicer pictures
later in his presentation so I'm not
showing this too long but
um crucial markers for cortical neurons
are expressed as well as glutamatergic
and gabaergic markers
so a recent publication actually used
these ngn2 overexpressing lines as a
co-culture system with astrocytes and
that was carried out in collaboration
with Janssen Alfredo Cabrera from the
Amazon and he showed that these ngn2
derived neurons are actually Superior
towards duel's met differentiated
movements when co-cultured with
astrocytes and that their activity is
very similar to that of primary Mouse
neurons so for example the resting
membrane potential of the ngn2 derived
clearance was at minus 60 millivolt
whereas it's all the analyzed humans
which were differentiated with the duals
mat differentiation protocol which are
shown here and do at the left side had
only a resting membrane potential of
around -40 and upon depolarization the
energy into a lot many more engine into
derived neurons were actually generating
action potentials
so and those were found to be active
similar to that of primary muscle
cultures
we have deposited several lines at
eBay's a wild type line boundary Orton
C13
but we also have deposited lines NG and
two lines in combination with mutations
in the map teaching
now the last example that I would like
to give is also an inducible Gene of
assignment clean snca this is a very
important risk Gene for Parkinson's
Disease and
in Parkinson's disease or Parkinson's
disease on the molecular level can be
characterized by the formation of
so-called Louis bodies and these
inclusions are formed by misfolded off a
simultane
so unsuitable insoluble forms aggregated
forms of alphason
so we have generated a line where Alpha
Silo clean was inducible Upon A docs
application
and the suggestion is that other theory
is that the
application of alpha cyanide clean
actually is a spreading
um a spreading mechanism like a prime
light mechanism so that if you have one
misfolded officer of a simultane
molecule that this can lead to the Mis
to Mis to the misfolding of other of
assignment in proteins
so we have a
generated or established in uh
collaboration with Lundberg Tina
Stoneman and Charlotte from noon pack a
seating essay where we have used these
lines of assignment in over expression
lines
for a so-called seating essay we first
generated misfolded off a sign up in
Aggregates that was done in vitro just
by boiling them in a following a certain
protocol we received these three growths
and then we treated our neurons that we
have derived from our offer simultaneous
overexpressing IPS cells
and then we analyze them for two
characteristics the first was the
phosphorylation of ultrasonic in because
this is a prerequisite of uh aggregate
formation so we looked at the
phosphorylation pattern of the
phosphorylation status of the endogenous
or the uh
this office annual team which was
expressed in the cells the
phosphorylation status of the
induction's office hydroclean and then
we also look at the aggregation using a
threat essay
and here these two graphs the upper
graph is showing the phosphorylation
when we not add when we are not adding
doxycycline at the left side you can see
there was no phosphorylation of the
endogenous ultrasonic limbs or
overexpressed ultrasound
sorry not overexpressed because we
didn't end talks of course but when we
added the seeding material there was no
phosphorylation of the endogenous of a
cytokine only when we ins when we
treated the cells with docs and when
Alpha simultane was overexpressed we
found that phosphorus that Alpha
Cyanogen became postulated
and in the lower graph we can actually
see the aggregation of of a Cyanogen of
the endogenous of a cyanoclean again at
the left side we only added seating
material but we didn't add docks and
here at the right side we added dots but
here for the zero we didn't add seating
material and we did not see application
of the endocious of a simultane but in a
dose dependent manner by adding the
seeding material the endogenous of
assignment in was actually forming
aggregates
so this was a seating essay as an
example for a disease model for
Parkinson's Disease and I would like to
finish with this uh figure which is
showing the aggregated alpha salute in
in the cells by Amino cytochemistry
um the cells were stained with Mach 2 a
neuronal marker and with an antibody
detecting phosphorylated Alpha cytokine
at Precision 129 and since the
endogenous are the overexpressed of the
Cyanogen was expressing was
coupled to an ha type it was traceable
with an H A recognizing antibody and all
the yellow dots you can see here is
endogenous hyperphosphorylated Alpha
cytokine in our cells
and that's the end of my presentation
and now I would like to hand over to my
colleague Peter Reinhardt
thank you very much Benjamin and so just
uh to correct you so I feel already very
old because it has been I checked it I
think 13 years that we started working
on this project once together
So yeah thank you very much for this
very kind
um introduction and also for your great
presentation
um
I would like to
um take take it from here and
um show you an example of how we are
enabling
um the use of ipsc derived cells and in
particular ipmc derived neurons in our
daily research routine so just a very
short disclaimer
um the we are employees of appv and
therefore we all receive royalties from
Epic
so Benjamin already gave an excellent
introduction into inducible reporting
stem cells and this is just a brief
recapitulation on top
um why we think that IPS shelter such
great models so
um you can make them donor specific
um at least theoretically you can grow
as many cells of them as you want
um if you know why if you know how then
you can guide them into a specific cell
type they are genetically detractable as
Benjamin could nicely present to you and
if you talk about
neurons in particular so for the first
time they really allow you access to
functional human cells at scale for in
vitro experiments
so on the bottom I want to show you um
that I mean of course
um in our daily routine and also in our
daily research and we don't always work
with IPC derived cells there's there are
many many good reasons
um to also use for example other in
vitro models to use immortalized cell
lines and if you have a very specific
question that these can answer well
enough there is no reason to use a more
complex model but of course these ipsc
derived neurons at least will have a
putatively higher disease relevant when
you think about neurological diseases
but at the same time and this is
something I want to elaborate a little
bit more on
also there is at least a perceived
complexity of the method that is
definitely increased over using um
traditional saline based models in vitro
so
um how do we allow um or how do we
facilitate the use of ipsc derived
models
um
so on the one hand
and you can see on the right hand side
so starting from exploratory studies
small genetic proof of concept studies
knocking down knocking out over
expressing specific genes targets or
modulators of disease mechanisms also
allowing small molecule or genetic
screening applications targeted or
large-scale screenings
but also then supporting ongoing
projects in the screening funnel
compound characterization on a regular
base talking here about cycle time
essays that are performed on a regular
base but also even possible applications
very far down the line in for example
development Sciences
um
so on the one hand we allow this or we
achieve this by growing our pool of
expertise but also our pool of experts
so it is not that
um having having been exposed to IPS
cells is such
um an exclusive thing anymore so we are
of course growing our colleagues
um they by that have experience with IPS
cells but also by organizing and
conducting internal meetings such as
such as an ipsc Forum but also
um very important exchanging and writing
up very detailed Sops
and our goal is here to reduce the at
least perceived complexity of ipsc
derived models to really allow fit for
purpose application of these models in
um in our research and one thing I
always like to compare it to is that how
can we lower the
um the activation energy of the
scientists really using IPC derived
models in their daily routine and also
in their
research projects to the best possible
outcome
there is a there are about various cell
types um derived from IPS cells which
are established in FV Neuroscience
Discovery
um so these are shown here on this on
this overview slide
and so to generate these cells we either
use protocols which are adapted from
published protocols and but also parts
of them are our own developments and and
these and there are modifications so
that they really fit into our schedule
timeline and also the um scale that is
needed
and for each of these we make sure that
for this routine differentiations and
applications so also how to apply the
cells in a specific model that there are
detailed sop is generated and used and
shared and also one thing that I would
like to mention here that is very
important to keep these Sops up to date
and also to track all the changes that
you do based on your let's say daily
observations or let's say modifications
that are very important for your
specific question because it does not
help you if you find in that book later
on that says oh it was differentiation
was performed according to that protocol
but you don't know which version of the
protocol and if there were like a lot of
changes made afterwards
and to give you an example so I think we
can really um show that this was
achieved quite well so you can see here
on this graph this is just on the
example of the ipsc derived cortical
neurons as one of the cell types that we
regularly generate from IPS cells you
have in blue
um the number of cells and here in
millions and for for M that are plated
on essay ready plates so that scientists
can use to directly perform the
experiments but in red the number of
plating ready neurons that were
generated and you can see that these are
more and that these are even increasing
more strongly compared to the blue line
and how is this
um of course we are not just plating
um the double or amount of cells in the
same plate format and also unfortunately
um we are not growing our team that
dramatically but this is just that these
flight University cells are being
handled by the scientists themselves
that need them later in their
experiments and so this is just achieved
by that these scientists are more
trained so they take over more parts and
later parts of the protocols we
simplified and aligned the communication
and hand over for the essay ready plates
and also we establish more efficient
procedures for generating the cells and
also larger cell batches
but it is really important to empower
the scientists to use and also make
partially their own ipsc derived cells
so that the IPS cells move out of this
let's say niche of these fancy cells
that people are afraid to touch to
really make them widely applicable and
prevent that the supply of cells is
simply any a bottleneck to any project
and this is just to give you a graphical
overview over of over our cell banking
procedure for the ready
um to use ipsc batches so when these
cells come in and we get them for
example from collaborators
um or the IR obtained from
um the cell Banks such as ebis which is
a great resource that Benjamin mentioned
already
um
they are briefly expanded and the very
small batches Frozen away for long-term
backup but also distributed within the
organization
these are then used to generate first a
master cell Bank in this master cell
Bank typically contains around 50 miles
part of it the small part is sent out
for external storage in case something
happens here to our liquid nitrogen
storage
and then each of these vials is then
always used to generate a working cell
bank and the working cell bank is aimed
at around 80 up to 100 or more vials and
one of these vials typically contains 10
to 20 million viable cells per vial
after sawing the viability should be
above 90 percent and this really helps
everybody and a great deal in the lab
because you don't need to maintain a
running culture or you don't take care
of freezing your own cell batches and
you can imagine you know I mean I
remember these days when you had like I
don't know 20 different passages Frozen
away and then you know had some fiddly
handwriting on these vials and then you
had the secret Excel sheet where it was
marked where these are and also that
don't use dispatch and use this badge
and then there's only two vials left and
you need more for your experiments and
this is really and aim to allow people
to just go there take a while saw them
up put them in their experiments don't
need to typically expand them a lot
before
um doing your differentiation or your
experiments and then always be able to
go back to the same badge to forward
experiments and have the same expected
user experience
so these banks are also then QC and some
QC parameters of course are sterility
including microplasm testing viability
post saw growth so how are they
expandable but also expression of
expression of potency markers and of
course also checking kyrotypical
Integrity one thing that is very
interesting here is that these cells we
have not found any major chromosomal
aberrations even after making these
large cell batches so far but of course
you can never be sure so better be safe
than sorry
and now this is then um the part
um where we get to how to make the the
cells in question that we need for our
experiments and this is just a very
beautiful example here of a very
detailed and a um extremely nicely
working protocol that colleagues from us
um
established um in our Cambridge Side
um to differentiate cortical neurons out
of ips cells so this
um is outlined above and there is a
stage in between where these cells can
be frozen away and banged as large
batches of cortical neuroprogenitor
cells NPCs which are then briefly
pre-differentiated and then plated into
the final essay format or the final
plates for analysis and this protocol is
not only aimed at the differentiation of
dorsal excitatory cortical neurons and
also shown here by the if staining above
but um also that these cells really
provide cells that are nicely
distributed single cellular distribution
and ideal for Imaging purposes for
example I'm observing aggregated Tau
protein and these can be also maintained
for extremely long time so even months
after the plating and they stay like you
can see it on the bottom right side so
they really are staying if these nicely
beautiful
single separated cells which is very
important for long-term cultures
but you can also anticipate and this is
something that Benjamin already
mentioned before that this is a lengthy
process you take a long time to get to
the
um let's say plating essay ready cells
um and also this is something that not
everybody can do without having at least
a decent experience in handling IPS
cells so therefore another protocol that
already already also Benjamin had
mentioned and shown is that and the use
of these ingn2 or inducible neurogen in
two neurons the protocol is much shorter
it is outlined in the upper left hand
corner so only two days of a
pre-differentiation step where these
cells are exposed to doxycycline which
then triggers the expression of the
pro-neurogenic transcription Factor
neurogenic 2. this Dash to push them
into a proneuronal phase and then and
these cells are either directly replated
or more conveniently Frozen and at that
stage
as a single cell suspension and of
course you can imagine here that it's
much easier to generate large batches of
pre-differentiated cells and that are
then ready to be plated just on the
essay plates whenever you need them
and these cells show the rapid
expression of glutamatergic Market genes
mature Market genes shown by real-time
PCR on the bottom but also shown here by
if staining but also um on the western
plot analysis showing the Tau expression
as a mature neurological marker
so these models and also shown here by
either the calcium Imaging and used as a
method but also by using the
multi-electrode array so we use a
um typically use them by astral Pro
System here which is a very convenient
tool for somebody like me who is not
deeply experienced with doing
electrophysiology so analyzing these
cultures and this is a very important
question we are always ask like so when
do these cells become
electrophysiologically functional
and of course there are different
measures to it but if you look for
example on the right hand side
um you can see that thanks to the
optimized medium compositions and the
maturation conditions that we are using
we are able to
um show functional neurons by for
example the number of active electrodes
or bursting electrodes
um around three weeks after the final
plating and this is We Believe
relatively short and also something that
we can reproducibly see and this is very
important of course for Downstream
applications and this is also something
I want to mention here these are only
neurons and we can show that we have
more or less pure neuronal cultures and
not really
um
and and not for example cultures um with
astrocytes that I will briefly touch
upon later
so one um very nice application and an
example of um how we can use these cells
I want to give here is a
um
as an as an example of a targeted
screening approach
um that we are applying on a more
regular basis and the clearance of
aggregated Tau protein as a therapeutic
strategy for Alzheimer's disease
Tau protein which is forming upon this
Aggregate and this folding and
aggregation the so-called
neurofibrillary Tangles is a
pathological Hallmark of Alzheimer's
disease and so the field believes that
the appearance and the spread of the
aggregated towel then correlates with
the cognitive decline and this is
something you want to contact
so once a therapeutic strategy that
um
um we follow is that we want to clear
the aggregated Tau protein and so these
neurofibrillary Tangles either in direct
or more indirect way should be targeted
towards the um degradation Machinery of
the cells so either for example
proteosomal degradation or autophagy
and to do that to follow that up we
developed this very simple but very
robust essay here and this is shown in
this cartoon so
um these ipsc derived cortical neurons
are tagged lentivirally with a gfp they
are transduced with a lentil by with the
gfp tact Tau
um carrying the aggregation phone prone
p301l mutation and then upon the
addition of recombinant
sonicated pareteleco filaments spphs as
Tau seeds you can see that in a around
about two weeks incubation time followed
by methanol fixation to remove the
soluble Tau protein you can very nicely
see and observe and calculate and count
these Tau Aggregates which are formed
and this is
um this is very convenient because now
now immuno fluorescent staining is
required and also as you can see on the
graphs on the bottom this is something
that is very well tolerated so the
number of healthy nuclei is typically
not affected by this so you don't see
any cell death using these conditions
but you can very nicely correlate the
number of Tau gfp Aggregates per nucleus
on the amount of the Tau SPH apps that
are added to this culture
the same system just replacing the
lentiviral delivery of a gfp tact Tau
protein you can replace with this gfp
tagged alphasonically in carrying the
a53 T mutation and same principle here
upon the addition of recombinant
facility in pff's seats this is then
um
and incubated and within three weeks
following the methanol fixation we can
observe these very nice Aggregates which
are being formed also here this is not
affecting the unviability of the cells
directly but we can see that this is
showing this nice concentration
dependent formation of the alpha symbol
in gfp aggregates
and one way of how to use this and this
is showing you
um the the optimization that was
performed the aggregation of these um
these Tau gfp Aggregates is time
dependent so the longer you wait and
also there is an optimal window for the
aggregation of this
we try to optimize this and we found out
that at least 14 days plus the sphs
Edition is needed to really develop a
decent assay window and then to really
calculate the time of adding the
Aggregates but also the time needed for
the aggregate for the Tau aggregate
formation and this was correlated with
each other and we then developed this
very convenient and reproducible 28a
protocols on the right lower corner and
this is I'm showing to us the best pro
and the best compromise for time
efficiency but also aggregate formation
with a decent essay window
and the way that this essay was used and
this is showing here data from an
ongoing project is for example for
compound characterization and then
within nine months I'm using just 96
will format
um 215 plates were performed on a M
regular base so typically 16 plates per
week to analyze compounds coming from a
ongoing project and to be characterized
before the modifications are made to
these compounds in the next round
and we also plotted
um the Z Prime which is an indication
for the fa sa
um for the SA reproducibility or for the
robustness of the essay if you look at
the Z Prime
um this is not a humongous Z Prime if
you compare it with other cell based in
vitro essays with around 0.4 but still
this is a very decent set Prime for such
a complex essay so we are very happy
about that and we have getting we are
getting very good results especially
um considering that this is a relatively
stable is that Prime so this is not
moving too much over time if you see
here these are really independent
experiments over a long period of time
and at the same time another example of
how such an essay can be used and now
here
um using a genetic perturbation using a
genetic screen so this is a targeted
genetic knockdown screen
so and we were able to establish a
protocol with very strong very well
tolerated and very persistent G
knockdown using delivery of s-i-rna
using the Tau genes are shown on the
lower right hand graph the map t as the
first treatment condition
as a technical positive control
technical positive control meaning of
course if you knock down towel including
the Tau gfp this is not going to
um aggregate them
and we were able to perform
um here the screen of 100 genes of
Interest so gois in the 961 format and
within a given timeline that was very
very tough but this was a very
successful application of this essay so
these um we performed in total five
independent screens using different
starting cell types partially and also
some minor modifications and that were
performed in this 96 were format and
then just um from the 20 top genes and
you can see here an example of the top
hits of the screening of the round
number five
and you can also see that the four
valves of the replicates are really
lying nicely together
and very reproducibly looking
um so and then these were validated in
two independent validation screens
um and we were able to then come up with
a our clearly and very robust topic of
the genes that in this essay system
modulate the presence of these Tau
Aggregates most likely by the
degradation by the already mentioned
mechanisms either protozober or through
the autophagy
so yeah and this is just uh let's say
just not not even an Outlook but this is
showing you some further applications
and now I was talking about specifically
how to really Implement more robust
models how to implement
um something that also not so I can see
experience scientists can Implement in
their daily routine but we are also
working on much more complicated models
so this is an example of our IPC derived
neuron astrocyte micro gear core culture
system we call it the triculture
and um this outlined above so first
neurons are plated then astrocytes are
added and then macrophage precursors
which are then further um maturing into
microbial-like cells in the school
culture system and
um this is not only a very robust 20-day
protocol and also allowing longer term
cultures but also we could show that
different donors couldn't be combined
and this is very important because
um like this you can really mix
different
um genotypes of questions from the one
cell type and the other and you can look
at interactions how they influence each
other and
this also can be combined with Tau
seating or aggregation assays in these
cells I mean of course you can induce
how aggregation in these neurons and
then observe it and try your conclusions
and I mean last but not least of course
as you can see down there these um
co-cutions also generate amazing
pictures so something you can directly
put up on a poster or on the cover of a
magazine wave one time
yeah so this is um bringing me to the
end of um my part of the presentation
and just to quickly sum up so ipsc
derived um yeah cells can be very
efficiently used as a disease model in
vitro for neurodegenerative diseases
but we have found out the application of
these models can be sometimes limited
just by the reluctance of of people to
establish a more complicated cellular
system and so by by training and writing
Sops and also the logistics and
Generation by for example the generation
of large cell dutches this can be
overcome and so we really see now these
models been really widely applied in
many different parts of the projects and
also in many different projects
themselves
and
um try to give you an example how
specific aspects of neurodegenerative
diseases can be robustly modeled in
these ipsc derived neurons so for
example the aggregation of toe protein
or alphysemically and
that these models and can be applied for
a genetic or a compound characterization
experiments but also for larger
screening applications which we are also
doing
so I hope we still have some time for
some questions and I very hope happy now
to tell you that this is the time for it
and opening up the presentation for the
Q and a session and thank you very much
for your attention
foreign thank you Benjamin and Peter for
your informative presentation we will
now start the live q a portion of the
webinar
if you have a question you'd like to ask
please do so now just click on the ask
the question box located on the far left
of your screen and we'll answer as many
of your questions as we have time for so
let's get started
our first question here is for Peter and
this question asks do you see
differences with different ipsc clones
or even lines from different donors
yeah
um excellent question
um this is a very good one because and
yes there are yeah so I mean this is one
of the reasons why I always say that I
am differentiation Protocols are only as
good as long as you find out that they
are not working
um so we have seen it that
um there are certain IPC lines that are
reluctant to a specific differentiation
process
um this is I mean also widely described
in the literature but um yes if you want
to really be sure you have to try it out
but nevertheless also with time you are
going to end up with more reproducible
Protocols of course so this is a process
that goes so to say like this together
but that happens yes
great thank you next question here is um
for Benjamin and this question asks is
it possible to engineer inducible or
conditional Knockouts so that the gene
is functional in the stem cells but can
be knocked out and differentiated
neurons
yes we have done that a few times
however it's much more complicated than
a conventional knockout so we were using
um the cree lock system where we have
inserted the pre-recombination to a safe
side Locus and we had then inserted
blocks key size surrounding
a certain action of our chain of
interest and when we add a docs Cree was
expressed and was locked was then
looping out this Axon
this is however much more complicated
than a normal knockout but it definitely
has worked in the past yes
great
another question for you Benjamin is
could you please elaborate on the role
of having selection marker in order to
generate knock and so on
um yes I've done that as well so we were
using plasmids however plasmids always
have the risk of random integration and
wrong integration
so the strategy was to insert a
selection marker in the subsequent axon
in the in the subsequent entrance sorry
so if you want to change for example a
base in a certain axon you make sure
that the selection marker is located in
subset in the downstream intron
um and then you hope of course that the
selection Market does not interact with
the splicing mechanism
um so that's for example one risk that
the splicing mechanism doesn't work
anymore when you have inserted something
into the subsequent in front
um we are not using it
um the efficiency is high enough to do
Gene editing without selection markers
great thank you
next question here is for Peter and this
question asks how do you ensure
reproducibility when differentiating
ipscs to reduce variability for example
batch to batch
yeah I mean reproducibility is very
important and I mean you cannot always
guarantee it but very simply said I mean
on the one hand of course try to make
your protocols as robust as possible try
to also uh you know
um don't prolong your differentiation
longer than you would need to see an
effect or observe what you want to
observe but at the same time I think the
biggest
thing you can do from from our point of
view is is to use large batches um so
when you have these pre-differentiated
cells for example this cortical neural
progenitor cells or the
pre-differentiated neurons with the
engine 2 protocol
um so we normally aim at patches in the
range of billions of cells and then like
really more than 100 vials of a stock of
these cells so that you can dedicate
these to ongoing projects or repetitive
requirements and
that normally works well if your
protocols or Sops are in place that you
can expect a reproducible experience
here
great thank you
next question is for Peter and this
question asks what assays and
applications would you like to use the
tri-culture model for studying
neurodegeneration
um yeah thank you for this one
um the tri-culture model I mean it's uh
it's it's something that we are I'm very
happy about that that we can play with
it so to say um but playing is not the
right thing so it's um I mean you can
imagine a lot of things
um just to give you an example uh there
is something that is called um the
disease Associated microclear so one um
thing that we take is to take these
um Micro Clear under different
conditions or and being exposed to
different neurons or differently so
quote unquote sick neurons for example
and then really
um and see how this affects their
possible disease Associated
um phenotype so very
um superficially one could call this
neural inflammation but we have a
department working on this question and
they would just let me on the back of my
head if I called it neural inflammation
because it's not as simple as that yeah
wait another question for Peter here
this attendee mentioned I like the
tri-culture model how do you manage
different media requirements for neurons
versus astrocytes versus microglia also
do the cells in tri-culture
de-differentiate
um yeah different media requirements so
one thing that is very clear is you
cannot just use any medium that's a very
good one
um but in the end
we just use a what we call co-cultural
medium so this is um based on the on the
a protocol from Celly cow this lab so
which is a great protocol for making
microclear like cells and this is a very
basal medium in the end it comes down to
just leaving everything out and the
cells also one thing you observe they
really greatly support each other so
these three cell types and one of the
reasons and this is a just one example I
want to close this reply with is that if
you use these classical neuronal
supplements like B27 or B27 plus these
will normally come with a lot of
corticosteroids and this is something
that Michael clearly will not like
um this in there because it was
developed originally for primary
cultures and do they differentiate no we
have not seen it over at least the time
that we observed this for which is at
least um
plenty of weeks
question is
for Benjamin and um Peter feel free to
chime in as well if you have any um
thing to add here so this question asks
for disease modeling purposes would you
prefer patient-derived clones with known
genetic aberration or rather edit these
aberrations into healthy donor clones
difficult question I I I've gotten this
question a lot in the past so of course
if you have a patient with a certain
mutation or with a risk factor let's
maybe start with the risk factor a risk
factor is normally
um uh snip or a base change that doesn't
necessarily need to lead to the outbreak
of the disease it requires that there
are other markers that there are other
genes also that you have other Snips
um present in the cells to make it work
so if you now want to insert such as
such a risk factor into a healthy donor
you don't know whether it indeed will
have an effect in these cells in
combination with the genetic background
that this individual has
um so in case of risk factors I would
always prefer a patient line
in terms of monogenetic diseases where
you know for example for Alzheimer's
disease there is present lean which is a
monogenetic uh this monogenetic marker
or marginal Gene
um where you know that this mutation
leads to the outbreak of the disease you
can insert this one into a healthy donor
and then you can of course benefit from
a healthy donor at a higher age which
who doesn't show any signs for new
degeneration and then by inserting for
example into an 80 years of eight eight
years old individual mutation
that's a quite good
tool to study the location
great yeah so I can just chime in and I
think that what you just said is
absolutely correct
um
have already mentioned before that your
differentiation protocol might sometimes
not always work with the same as
different lines one of the benefits of
just starting with a donor you already
have and you know well is
that you know it's going to work most
likely in your differentiation protocol
and on the other hand also from a
company perspective I mean editing a
modification into an existing line
already gives you normally
um I mean you know the freedom to
operate with these cells and getting
access to Patient material in the
company having all the donor content in
place that is being used also for profit
purposes is not always that easy so of
course also this is something to be
taking consideration
um
right we're getting so many great
questions in from our audience and it
looks like we can try to squeeze a few
more in here so we'll go ahead and
continue this next one is for Benjamin
and this is um does have a few parts to
it so this question says you mentioned
that customers typically do not ask for
crispr off-target analysis but how do
you approach assessing these off targets
I imagine that this becomes increasingly
important once you start introducing
multiple edits accumulation of
off-target edits perhaps
yeah it's it's indeed surprising so
um it's very sound that we are asked
about checking for our Target effects
um we have done this in the past by
sequencing analyzes so we just sequenced
um the most
uh most related sequences
um when you are designing a crystal
you're normally told related sequences
so you're getting a certain Gene and
you're being told that this Gene also
fits can be targeted by the crispr with
only three or two mismatches
um we have done that a few times and
we've never detected an off-target
effect by sequencing
um we have not used
um
a deep sequencing so we have a whole
genome sequencing to cover the whole
genome we only use specific sites in the
genome that we were suggested by the
crispr
um yeah when we are generating the crisp
of Target effects
um yes I hope that covers the question
like we have time for one more question
here so we'll go ahead and wrap up with
this one and Peter this one's for you
this question asks in the co-culture
system there are many factors in
cytokines released from one cell type
well they interfere with other cells and
also do they affect differentiation the
differentiation process
um yes
um that's that's an interesting one I
mean it's of course I mean these cells
will talk to each other I mean one of
the purposes of doing that um co-culture
system and then one very nice example
here is the the microplia cell so I mean
these are not added as microteal cells
but they are added as macrophage precurs
and so
um which are primitive uh monocyte like
cells that are then just by the glues
getting from the medium and also getting
from the neighboring cells they are then
transforming into this microclear-like
and also quite microclear comparable
State
um yes this is clearly going on
um
they and so that also means that they
affect the differentiation process
um of course there is only things
um you can or specifically manipulate
that you look for or that you um know of
that is inside one application of this
system is also that in a single
um cell or a sequencing analysis for
example we are trying to look here for
um possible crosstalks on a
transcriptional level so for example one
cell type is expressing one cytokine and
another neighboring cell type is
expressing the corresponding receptor so
we can also then try to build these
networks so yesterday will interfere but
of course to really let's say look into
the culture this is something very
difficult to achieve experimentally
eight well Peter and Benjamin do you
have any final comments for our audience
not from my side
um I just can say thank you for the
great questions
um and also for everybody listening
okay
great yeah also thanks for my side it
was a pleasure giving this presentation
this webinar
wonderful well thank you Benjamin and
Peter for your time today and your
important research we would also like to
thank lab roots and our sponsor bioneer
as for underwriting today's educational
webcast
before we go I'd like to thank the
audience for joining us today and for
their interesting questions questions we
did not have time for today and those
submitted during the on-demand period
will be addressed by the speakers via
the contact information you provided at
the time of registration
this webcast can be viewed on demand and
labyrinths will alert you via email when
it's available for replay we encourage
you to share that email with your
colleagues who may have missed today's
live event until next time take care
everyone goodbye
thank you bye